[Music]
do you know what i just realized
i'll treat this as a lovely road trip
through italy and i'll just pretend that
you are still my devoted husband
and you please you will be you will be
the human luggage yes
we are now on honeymoon first of all
it's a mission
second of all and just so we're clear i
promised my therapist no bodyguarding so
i'm not protecting
either one this is
need to be created in a stimulating
environment
i must be aroused by sightseeing
shopping fine dining but we are
officially
on honeymoon did she say fine dining
let's not do that guys let's just focus
on the road here oh can we go
all right i got it no it's fine you guys
just
you guys have had him maybe feather the
break a bit
[Music]
you're gonna tell us everything you know
i'm not telling you a mother
you can electrocute him all day it'll
only make him angrier
i on the other hand will tell you
everything really
michael bryce was trying to put his past
behind him you need to forget
bodyguarding repeat after me
no bodyguarding no
roddy carting then he got pulled back in
let go jesus to protect this homicidal
nut bags
wife what is he doing here i said get
anyone but
michael rice i believe it's pronounced
thank you
in four days all of you loved was burned
they're planning a full-scale cyber
attack do not scoop this up but we are
definitely
gonna screw this up i promised my
therapist no bodyguarding let's not do
that guys let's just focus
i got it no it's fine you guys just you
guys have had it
maybe feather the break a bit i need you
to protect
us good time to have a baby
we gotta have mercy on ourselves now
repeat after me
i'm unlicensed i'm unlicensed that's
terrible
louder i'm unlicensed and i don't give
up
we need guns we need boats
we need them are you ready to get your
freak on
what that came out wrong not together
with us that also came out wrong now
let's go do what we do
and blow some things up
i would make a great mother tongue i
think your glasses thank you
it must be your powerful asexuality that
makes you such a good listener
we just acknowledge that not only are we
safe this really feels like a newbie
[Music]
so